il est presque cinq heures du matin
alors que la majorité des habitants de
villeneuve la guyard dort encore georges
prend la roue du travail il faut se
rêvait 4 heures du matin le temps de se
préparer pour le prendre centrale
direction la gare sur le quai il
retrouve d'autres navetteurs beaucoup
d'entre eux travaille en région
parisienne mais on fait le choix de
venir s'installer dans l'yonne
pour georges c'était il ya dix ans je
suis resté 25 ans à vitry sur seine
au fil du temps on s'est décidés avec
madame de dalles et l'échangé des vicois
et le prix à payer c'est la distance le
train il faut se réveiller très tôt le
matin ce pénible effectivement mais on
s'y fait avec le temps
comme lui ils sont près de 9400 et koné
a occupé un emploi en ile de france
synonyme de trajet quotidien dans les
transports en commun au début c'est un
peu dur mais après on prend l'habitude
et puis comme c'est chez nous on est le
trajet passe très vite
il était un peu plus de six heures
arrivé en gare de lyon direction le
métro parisien georges doit opérer deux
changements avant d'arriver à bon port
vous avez vu on est descendu du train en
redescend on monte les escaliers
là où il n'ya pas d'escalators on essaie
de marcher un petit peu à peu vie ça me
fait aussi un petit peu mon sport du hmf
matinale 1100 euros
si son budget annuel dédié au transport
malgré cela les trois heures
quotidiennes passées dans le train et le
métro
il ne regrette pas son choix d'avoir
quitté la région parisienne quand je
reviens de temps en temps voir où
j'étais je vois la différence je préfère
la vie dès la campagne ou jeu
pour prendre les transports tous les
jours pour venir au travail il est 6
heures 40 chauffeur de bus à la ratp
georges débute son service une nouvelle
journée à passer dans les transports
mais cette fois avec la casquette de
producteur